we actually have to re-embrace risk on a
personal level and on a societal level
we have to take the risk of freely
exchanging ideas because that's where
innovation happens we have to take the
risk of being able to invest and reap
the benefits of that risk in a personal
relationship getting married is a risk
it is foregoing a current benefit for a
future game every decision you make is a
risk the biggest risk of all of course
is the decision to be free and to take
responsibility for your own choices
that's a major risk but if you take that
risk you become a better and a stronger
human being a more contributing human
being a more valuable human being you
feel better about yourself when we
discard risk we discard meaning when we
are coddled we discard our own ability
to be a fully adult human being and
here's the here's the dirty little
secret no matter how much we tried to
discard the risk you can't actually
discard risk it's inevitable because
reality entails risk we can choose to
live free rather than coddled it'll make
us better people more open people more
understanding people
and when we do that i think that not
only will we be saving the country and
saving the civilization we'll be saving
ourselves